[Musique]
au rond-point remis à neuf nouveaux
parterres de fleurs nouvelle route qui
est lisse et à nouveau en délit pendant
des mois
objectif se montrer sous son meilleur
jour pour le 26e sommet du commonwealth
vos portes et déjà deux fois du fait de
la pandémie de co vide il est organisé
notamment dans ce bâtiment symbole de la
capitale sa construction a débuté en
2009 l'année où le rwanda rejoint le
coma noël de
l'école le centre de convention a été
inaugurée en 2016 pour attirer le
commerce international
et booster le secteur des conférences
il s'agissait de placer kigali sur la
carte du monde et le rwanda en fin de
compte concurrencer le reste des grandes
villes du
inspiré de la forme d'une hutte royal le
centre de conventions attire des
visiteurs du monde entier objectif
remplir les hôtels de la capitale et
vendre les activités touristiques du
pays pour faire tourner l'ensemble de
l'économie de services du rwanda
le commonwealth doit aussi bénéficier à
de nombreux autres secteurs en
favorisant les échanges entre ses
membres à nabeul et je crois que les
bonnes relations entre le royaume-uni et
le gouvernement du rwanda ont joué un
rôle important dans une ferme y aux
exportateurs de développer leur commerce
avec le royaume uni
qu'on peut comparer à d'autres marchés
dans le monde le royaume uni nous
fournit des taxes minimal sur nos
produits et cela attire donc des
exportateurs c'est vrai pompon
c'est tout un système avantageux taillé
pour les pays en développement comme le
rwanda aujourd'hui 95 % de sa production
est exportée vers le royaume uni en 2020
son entreprise il envoyé deux tonnes de
piment gronder par semaine
aujourd'hui elle atteint près de 7
tonnes il ya bien sûr l'absence de taxe
mais aussi une proximité linguistique
nouvelle entre les deux pays si
auparavant le rwanda était largement
francophone le pays s'est tourné vers
l'anglais depuis quelques années
[Musique]
l'anglais est devenu la langue
d'apprentissage en 2008 et la dernière
classe de primaire ce virage a continué
depuis 2000 21 les classes de cp étudie
entièrement en anglais
c'est une bonne chose que les enfants
étudient en anglais dès la première
année
nous aurons terminé ils pourront trouver
un emploi et être compétitifs sur le
marché international où beaucoup parler
anglais
pour nous les enseignants ce changement
était difficile
il l'est toujours
l'anglais désormais palais de la
primaire à l'université
c'est donc dans cette langue que la
délégation du commonwealth est venu
échanger avec des étudiants sur les
valeurs de l'organisation et son intérêt
pour les pays membres au cours de votre
discours vous avez mentionné que le
commonwealth a des valeurs alors quelles
sont ses valeurs
les droits de l'homme je voulais vous
demander comment le commonwealth nous
est il réellement
l'organisation appelle au respect de la
démocratie et des droits de l'homme sur
ce point la délégation prône le dialogue
amène de mort la démocratie et les
droits de l'homme la prospérité
économique sur le long terme font partie
de ce qu'est le common word il constitue
la charte du commonwealth en étant
membre et faisant partie du réseau du
common word
comme chez les pays comme le rwanda
peuvent bénéficier de l'expérience et de
la vie d'autres pays et dans ce cadre
nous sommes en mesure de discuter on
alliés de questions qui peuvent parfois
être délicate et difficile
dans sa 37è évaluation universel le
royaume uni lui même s'est fait critique
du bilan des droits de l'homme du pays
le rwanda est également régulièrement
pointée du doigt par les ong
nous attendons donc avec impatience plus
d'actions concrètes des autorités pour
garantir la liberté d'expression
améliorer les conditions de détention
des prisonniers
à réduire ou combattre les disparitions
forcées et mettre fin aux violations des
droits humains
il ya eu certains cas de personnes
décédées en détention
à partir de ce sommet à kigali le chef
de l'état rwandais paul kagamé assumera
la présidence exécutive de
l'organisation pour les deux prochaines
années
enjoint 24 organisations internationales
de la société civile ont signé une
tribune appelant les dirigeants qui
participeront à faire pression sur le
rwanda pour qu'ils lancent des réformes
et protège la liberté d'expression